we are a few days into Counter-Strike
2's first ever tier one land and so far
one question has been on everyone's mind
is the game actually ready for pro play
well the answer's a bit
[Music]
complicated it's no secret that Pro
players have been some of the most
outspoken when it comes to the current
state of Counter-Strike 2 many including
some of the best players in the world
are flat out on happy which is why I Was
preparing for I Sydney to be an absolute
[__] show if us plebs are already
experiencing issues on the regular what
sort ofy are we going to see in an
actual Pro match well right out of the
gate once players got to practicing they
immediately faced issues in the form of
what is currently CS 2's biggest problem
cheaters I played yesterday I had the
maximum was like 10 to 15 minutes que
and two of those games were the cheaters
so was great now mine is having to face
cheaters while you're trying to prepare
for a tournament worth a quarter of a
million dollars Spirits were still
pretty high even though Pros have been
some of the most vocal about cs2s issues
they've also been the most excited to
make the switch outside of simple a lot
seem to have a pretty open mind and when
ESL conducted their pre-t turning
interviews many voiced their complaints
but seemed cautiously optimistic I think
it's it's interesting you know like uh
the transformation from 1.6 CS go was
way worse so I think we have a great
game a great foundation of the game and
hopefully over time it's going to be
better and better like CIS go you know
CIS go wasn't perfect from day one that
I can tell you um but I like the many
new Tactical death and hopefully we'll
see that the the next following months
but people have to adjust first but now
that we've had a few days of seeing the
game actually played at the highest
level where the concerns valid is the
game ready for pro play hell is it even
ready for a spectator experience well if
you were to pull out all of the
highlights and watch them in a vacuum it
truly felt like we were just watching a
prettier version of Cs goo I'll admit it
probably helped that for whatever reason
the deagles were slapping that is a big
factor here as the swing big okay that
was quite a nice one from rain and car
carrian what he's got more left in the
tank as well as he peppers
acor I can't process what I just
witnessed what was that but outside of
this vacuum it's clear to tell that we
are actually dealing with a lot more
than just csgo with better graphics CS 2
is a new experience in a lot of ways and
we are probably going to see some
significant changes to the meta in the
weeks and months to come sure there
hasn't been any Olaf boost level cheese
yet but we've already seen how the
change to the bomb's explosion radius
has affected post plants as we know
players have to hike quite a bit further
to survive the bomb at the end of a
round if you've taken any damage that
distance can be pretty significant and
guess what on day one of group stages
we've already seen what the effects of
this look like the bom radius have been
increased in CS2 oh they're going for
some is he going to get to the bomb in
time I'm not sure well oh he's on it no
way he's on it oh he's going to squeeze
it oh my God Bobby big brain I told you
robs is the most dangerous man on the
server rain of the diffuse it'll be
interesting to see in the future if we
get more plays like this or if te's have
to sacrifice themselves more often to
get what used to be easy round wins
regardless the community is already
losing their fing Minds about this new
revelation and are pleading for valve to
change things back so business as usual
on the Counter-Strike subreddit now
outside of this very specific change to
the meta and maybe a few silly boosts
here and there have we actually seen any
significant gamebreaking issues I was
told that this game is a hot pile of
garbage that players are leaving in
droves surely Pros would be able to pull
back the curtain and show to the world
just how bad things truly are right well
things are more complicated than a
simple yes or no no answer you see there
is a very very significant issue right
now players are seemingly getting killed
by bullets that straight up shouldn't
have hit them crims gets one but it's
surely the end of it you've lost crims
now this is just one of many examples of
this happening either players dying
behind walls or generally getting killed
when they aren't even on screen I will
even admit this is sus as hell and
although the community always seems to
jump to blaming the sub tick Boogeyman I
kind of get it this time if the reality
is that we have a massive desync issue
on our hands or that sub tick is this
bad even on land this is fuing
ridiculous putting all of the what you
see is what you get memes aside This
truly takes me out of the game even if
it's so fast that I don't notice outside
of slowed down Clips posted to Reddit
knowing that it's even a possibility is
just always going to be in the back of
my mind I can't even imagine how Pros
would start to
feel nice with
he didn't shoot him that being said a
lot of people in the community are
claiming that this has more to do with
the fact that we're watching a spectator
cam rather than a onet toone of what the
players see others fired back saying
that this issue shouldn't be this
noticeable on land and even pointed out
that we didn't deal with this every
single day in csgo and while I do agree
I wonder if that's because we just
weren't looking before CS2 is rightfully
under a microscope but has it gotten so
bad that we're just being uncharitable I
think as the tournament continues a lot
more is going to come out and
potentially clear things up but if this
is truly a CS2 issue I wonder what
valve's response is going to be if they
have any but what do the actual players
think they're the ones with actual money
and careers on the line so their
opinions kind of hold more weight well
honestly the reactions have been mixed
and a little bit confusing Snappy who
has defended CS2 in the past recently
claimed that the game is in a very bad
State however he later clarified that
his intentions are only to help push the
game game to improve at the same time
twist says that he has no issue with the
game and that he's actually enjoying
himself some players are miserable and
others are confident that CS2 is already
on its way to becoming better than csgo
believe it or not some already think
it's there that being said if you look
on Reddit or online people still seem
unconvinced listen I think we all trust
valve to make an amazing game in the
future but we live in the present is
what we have acceptable it's dog [__]
mate like okay maybe the registration
everything will get better over time but
the game is out now it's not a beta it
may seem like one but it's not so we're
having to do this because of their
stubbornness I said it in a previous
video but like there were so many issues
when csgo first launched and in Pro play
and I just want to point out does anyone
remember how dusty the game was like it
was just Dusty you couldn't see anything
and it was like that for a little while
that was is surely worse than anything
we have now I think